priorité nationale et pour permettre
qu'un certain nombre d'allocations soit
soit réservé aux françaises la priorité
nationale clé de voûte du programme de
marine le pen n'est rien de nouveau
retour dans les années 80 quand c'était
son père jean marie le pen aux manettes
convenez avec moi qu'il vaudrait mieux
augmenter les prestations qui sont
réservés aux femmes françaises qui n'ont
que deux enfants plutôt que d'encourager
des femmes étrangères à avoir sur notre
sol trois quatre cinq enfants ou six
enfants et c'est la raison pour laquelle
le provost nationale proposée nous
aurons peut-être l'occasion d'y revenir
dans le cadre des propositions concrètes
que nous voulons faire que les services
sociaux soit en quelque sorte séparés
entre français et étrangers
1985 la formule préférence nationale
n'est pas encore lâché mais l'idée est
là elle sera théorisé quelques mois plus
tard par jean yves le gallou dans un
livre dans ce livre j'essaye non
seulement d'apporter un diagnostic
mais de montrer qu'il y a des solutions
au problème de l'immigration
le concept était né selon l'essayiste
membres du front national krivets les
étrangers des aides sociales serait un
moyen de pression pour les inciter à
quitter la france à partir de cette date
les cadres du parti d'extrême droite
feront de cette théorie leur credo
1988 il établit le principe de la
préférence nationale dans le travail
c'est à dire les français auront du
travail en priorité et les européens en
vertu de nos accords la priorité aussi
dans les services sociaux dans
l'attribution des hlm et les 6 millions
la politique familiale en 2006 nous
devons rendre aux français leurs
privilèges dans leur propre pays et ceci
passe par la préférence nationale et
quand marine le pen quand les rênes du
parti en 2011 c'est le même discours
avec un petit changement préférence
devient priorité la préférence nationale
que vous appelez aujourd'hui la priorité
nationale vous avez expliqué tout à
l'heure que c'était encore au coeur de
votre projet avec exactement les mêmes
arguments que son père ma philosophie
est la suivante ceux des étrangers qui
veulent venir sur notre territoire
doivent subvenir à leurs propres besoins
alors comment mettre en place cette
priorité nationale car de fait elle
instaure un principe de discrimination
contraire à la constitution là aussi la
réponse n'a pas changé depuis 35 ans une
révision de la constitution via un
référendum et il me paraît quand même
très important que le peuple français
soit interrogé sur le point de savoir si
ils souhaitent une france
pluriculturelle et multiraciale ou si au
contraire ils expriment un vote en
faveur d'une politique de préférence
nationale telle que nous la défendons
nous mêmes je vais inscrire dans la
constitution par l'intermédaire de ce
référendum une révision pour permettre
la priorité nationale mais pour faire
appel à l'article 89 qui pourrait
modifier la constitution il faut que la
question de ce référendum soit validé
par le sénat et l'assemblée nationale à
la majorité absolue un détail qui risque
de bloquer
[Musique]